hey everyone i am abby sharp welcome to
another edition of fertility files here
at Abby's kitchen now you may remember
that in some of my previous of fertility
files videos we talked about my personal
struggle with infertility in trying to
get pregnant and that one of the major
issues that I had in my journey was that
my uterine lining just didn't thicken
and that it was suggested that it was
possible that my long term use of the
birth control pill may have played a
role I was on the pill for 14 years
before which I had a totally normal
regular cycle but when I came off I just
never got a period so based on your
overwhelming interest in this topic I
wanted to dive deep into the research to
find out what the literature said about
the oral contraceptive use and long term
fertility I also acknowledge that I am
NOT a doctor and I'm specifically not a
reproductive endocrinologist or a
gynecologist so I am in no way giving
you any advice at all on your own use of
the birth control pill I am however
trained and analyzing research so what I
am planning to do today is to simply
regurgitate my findings as unbiased as I
possibly can and to bring you some
actual credible advice from some experts
in this unique field so I'm going to be
joined by my reproductive
endocrinologist dr. Tom hanim from
Hannam fertility clinic in Toronto as
well as mama dr. Jones to get their take
now before we get into this of course I
want to remind you that the information
in this video is for educational and
entertaining purposes only and you
should always speak to your doctor about
your unique healthcare case
okay so let's kick things off by
answering an important introductory
question how does the birth control pill
even work now the pill is an oral
contraceptive that contains synthetic
estrogen and progestin similar to the
hormones that naturally occur in a
woman's body in order to trick the body
into suppressing ovulation this takes
place because the pituitary gland
produces follicle stimulating hormone
which is FSH which in turn
stimulates the production of estrogen
and progesterone which lastly encourages
ovulation
now the synthetic hormones make the
pituitary glands produce less FSH
suppressing normal ovulation the birth
control pill also does a couple other
things to prevent unwanted pregnancy the
first is a thinning of the uterine
lining now a uterine lining of at least
8 millimeters in thickness is really
important for maintaining pregnancy as
that is the lining that the fertilized
embryo can nestle into for implantation
so to help prevent this from happening
the pill depletes glycogen stores to
thin out the lining the pill also may
thicken cervical mucus to prevent the
sperm from reaching any of the eggs
there's a lot going on in these teeny
tiny little pills now does the pill
affect future fertility
if you speak to most doctors most will
advise you that after a few cycles post
pill your body will return to its pre
pill state in fact a lot of the evidence
on contraceptive use and fertility is
actually quite reassuring once that he
found that ninety six point eight of
women got their period back within three
months after coming off the pill and
another study found that after one year
of pill use 57 percent of women got
pregnant after three months and 81
percent got pregnant after 12 months
there was even a study suggesting that
the longer women were on the pill up to
five years the greater their chances of
conceiving the rationale being that the
extended hormonal exposure may confer a
protective effect via minimization of
anomie trail proliferation and menstrual
shedding which would help prevent
endometriosis or endometrial dysfunction
however we do know that not all women
respond to medication the same and a few
studies as well as a lot of anecdotal
experiences have found that there can be
more significant delays in the return of
your period and ovulation which in turn
may impact fertility now research has
found that the pill may disrupt normal
menstrual function
but the length of this disruption is
really what's up for debate
one city found major cycle disturbances
after discontinuing oral contraceptives
including cycle length changes with more
than 35 days in the luteal phase or an
ovule Ettore cycles for up to nine
months after discontinuing the pill
another prospective study on over a
thousand women who discontinued the pill
because they wanted to conceive found
that the percentage of women who had
given birth after a year post pill was
about 32% for the pill thirty-nine
percent for an IUD and 54 percent for
vaginal barrier methods interestingly
while IUD users did fare better than the
pill users in the short-term the
long-term use of the IUD seemed to
really impact fertility with only 28% of
women who had used the IUD for 78 months
or more getting pregnant and delivering
compared to 46 percent of short-term
users another study compared pill users
with non hormonal diaphragm users and
found that after 12 months
70% of prior pill users had not yet
given birth
compared with 46 percent of women who
had used a diaphragm for contraception
the difference between groups did seem
to disappear after about 42 months post
pill but still three and a half years is
a long time when you're desperately
trying to conceive finally another study
evaluating a variety of contraceptive
methods found that it took 25% of former
pill users more than 13 months to
conceive after coming off the pill
compared to 12% and 8.5% of women using
IUDs and diaphragms respectively so the
research in this area as you can see is
clearly a mixed bag with some studies
finding no major differences in
contraceptive rates between pill users
and non pill users and others uncovering
some sobering stats it's very likely
that different women respond differently
to different drugs and there are a few
possible reasons why some women may
experience this fertility delay number
one the pills impact on uterine lie
first let's revisit how the pill thins
the uterine lining now because it's
ideal to have a thicker uterine lining
here probably about eight to fourteen
millimeters when you're trying to
conceive the birth control pill is
supposed to thin the uterine lining in
hopes of preventing an unwanted
pregnancy the question however is how
long it takes for a woman's uterine
lining to begin to thicken again after
discontinuing the pill and how would
this impact her future fertility
well while research in this area is
definitely in its infancy
one city conducted in 2012 found that
long-term birth control pill use about
five years or more can potentially limit
the growth of the endometrial lining aka
the uterine lining the study looked at a
hundred and thirty-eight patients and
found that those who had a uterine
lining thickness of seven millimeters or
thicker had a mean use of the birth
control pill of 5.8 years
while those who had a thickness less
than seven millimeters had a mean use of
nine-point eight years in other words
the longer you're on the pill the
potentially thinner the lining next
let's consider it the pills impact on
cervical mucus so another concern is the
fact that the pill thickens the cervical
mucus to prevent sperm from getting up
there now how long does this last after
discontinuing the pill unfortunately not
a whole lot of research has been done on
this topic however one city claimed that
after discontinuation menstrual
biomarkers such as length intensity
mucus score and ovulation were disturbed
for about two cycles after the two
cycles the biomarkers researched seemed
to start to regulate themselves given
some time now the third is the pills
impact on AMH levels now it's very
common for women who are trying to
conceive to get their anti-mullerian
hormone levels aka AMH tested to give an
idea of their overall fertility status
AMH is used to check a woman's ability
to produce eggs that can be then
fertilized for pregnancy where a higher
AMH is related to better chances of
concept
one study found that after nine weeks of
using oral contraceptives AMH levels
decreased in all women tested in another
study of 244 women that used oral
contraceptives there AMH levels were 19
percent lower than women who didn't use
them
lastly in another study 228 women who
used the pill had AMH levels lower than
women who didn't use it by almost a
third having said that there have also
been a number of studies that state the
complete opposite suggesting that the
pill did not have any effect on women's
AMH levels honestly it's hard to say
whether or not oral contraceptives lower
AMH levels in all women or how long it
may take before they resume but it makes
sense to get tested a few months
following discontinuation of the pill to
get some accurate results now finally I
want to talk about the pills impact on
ovarian aging now a lot of women who
struggle with fertility after being on
the pill are possibly diagnosed with
ovarian aging ovarian aging can make it
really difficult to conceive due to the
fact that the ovaries are receiving the
nutrients that they need to develop and
maintain a pregnancy
these nutrients include coq10 vitamin E
vitamin C and selenium in one study it
was found that women who were on the
pill had lower levels of coq10 and
vitamin E compared to women who were not
on the pill another study found that the
pill may also deplete nutrient levels of
folic acid vitamin b2 b6 b12 c e
magnesium selenium and zinc and most of
these are key players in reproductive
health in fact once that he found that
low levels of coq10 is a common
association with infertility in women
due to low mitochondrial activity in the
ovarian no sites this can explain why
women experience delays in fertility
after being on the pill without actually
having any pre-existing conditions I
also want to briefly touch on other
female health implications of the birth
control pill now in over 54 epidemia
logical studies over a hundred and fifty
thousand women were studied as well as
the relationship between the birth
control pill and breast cancer now women
who had taken oral contraceptives in the
past had a seven percent increase in the
risk of breast cancer while women who
were currently taking oral
contraceptives had a twenty four percent
increased risk another study found that
women who had taken the pill for over
five years had a 10% increased risk for
cervical cancer and any longer it was
about a sixty percent increased risk one
possible explanation for these findings
is that the synthetic hormones found in
the pill might increase the growth of
these cancers by binding to their
estrogen and/or progesterone receptors
well that's not all so great news you
might be happy to know that other
research has found that women who had
taken the pill had a reduced risk of
endometrial cancer as the pills presses
an Demetrio cell growth it may also help
reduce the risk of ovarian cancer by
decreasing the amount of ovulations a
woman experiences which in turn
decreases the exposure to naturally
occurring female hormones but if the
pill isn't to blame for my infertility
then what exactly is now there's no
denying that the hormones in the pill
may potentially impact short-term
fertility but there is also the
possibility that some women are
struggling with something else that was
sneakily present even before they
started the pill it's very difficult to
link post Pillowman areia directly to
the pill always due to the fact that
about one to two women get diagnosed
with a menorah after coming off the pill
out of every hundred so while the pill
may help regulate and manage PMS
symptoms it doesn't hear any
pre-existing conditions if present it
only covers them up so commonly masked
conditions include PCOS hypothalamic
amenorrhea and thyroid issues and when
mask a conditioned for a prolonged
period of time it can make it even more
difficult to regain your period
or your fertility once you come off the
pill so now that I have given you all
the research that I could find
I want to loop in my reproductive
endocrinologist dr. Tom hanim from hanim
clinic here in Toronto okay so first
question for you in your clinical
experience does the long term use of the
birth control pill impact women's
chances of conception and and if so in
your experience how does it do that the
good news is for most women using birth
control using birth control like birth
control pill is not going to be
consequential to their through to
fertility so women are positioned to be
taking the pill for example comfortably
for many women it actually makes for
easier cycles and and and confident that
their future selves will be able to
achieve pregnancy afterwards it's not
true for everybody but it is true for
most people that's that is that is very
reassuring because I mean for a lot of
women the birth control pill or any kind
of contraceptive is so important in
their lifestyle so right so maybe maybe
as a teenager because of the pain for
example around mansi's or just trying to
control regularity or of course for a
birth control so for a lot of them and
they've actually been on it for many
years
interesting during Lee during this time
of Tobit a lot of family doctor groups
chat groups are talking about how many
women are extending their pills so
people who have been thinking about
trying to achieve pregnancy a lot of
people are putting putting it off taking
the pill for a bit longer or keeping
their IUD in place for a little bit
longer just as they sort of watch them
figure out how everything's gonna settle
out so I could imagine there are a
number of people who would be watching
your channel both on the pill right now
and uncomfortable with the idea not want
to be a friend in this moment but very
much hoping to be getting pregnant very
interesting and and so for for those
those women who may be affected by the
pill what is going on there that that
may be causing those issues so the way
the pill was designed was to be an
estrogen like your natural estrogen
level and and naturally when your body
has lots of estrogen in the middle of
the cycle it doesn't stimulate any extra
growth so the idea behind the pill is
just get first
and the eggs going which is true that's
how it works the thing is it said the
estrogen is not your natural estrogen
averse
it's called ethanol estradiol is a
synthetic estrogen and it actually works
differently for every woman
everyone's body and it works differently
for different parts of their body so
that's why first of all a lot of women
have to find the right pill for them
just to try to find the right dose that
works but that makes them feel kind of
normal but even then it's never exactly
normal it's never exactly what it would
be naturally like to them with natural
estrogen levels these estrogens actually
interestingly they work as positive
estrogens in some places and negative
estrogens than others it's weird just
it's the way it binds to receptors so
for many women it will for example take
away hot flashes if a woman had a really
naturally low ascertain love it takes
the pill should look better that's a
good thing might help with bone density
for in similar ways but at the lining of
the interests for many women it actually
acts as an antioxidant so what that the
way she experiences that is having very
light mensies or no menses at all so a
lot of people watching this will be able
to recognize that they'll be like yeah
when they're taking the pill that will
have light or menzies than usual that's
actually can be for some that's a
feature not a bug so for example we're
talking about pain for some women
they're taking the pill because of pain
perhaps related to endometriosis so
having lower estrogen activity of the
uterus is actually a great thing and for
many women having a two or three day
man's either one to two day means these
might be preferable to having a heavy
four to seven day flow so there's value
to it for some but you have to
acknowledge that those women who are
having lighter mensies are having less
estrogenic activity to the uterus while
or while they're taking right that then
that does totally make sense and do you
see the same outcomes when we are
comparing different forms of
contraception like IUD NuvaRing birth
control pill i'm sure a lot of my
followers are going to wonder if one is
more safe than the others when it comes
to fertility so there's I don't have
specific studies to reference when I'm
talking about the safety of each of
those three things
it just comes down to personal
experience my personal experience I
think the NuvaRing is effectively a
little bit more antigenic than the birth
control pill and and the IUD is
different for everybody but for most
most women will have very light or no
menses indeed okay and so is that a good
indicator of the estrogenic activity yes
it is okay good good to know and why may
some women be affected by the pill but
others can go on the pill go off the
pill and then they conceived like the
next month right in fact for some women
it actually enhances the chances
conception right let's why do I keep
bringing up into mitosis but but women
are them you chose us it's a disease
where the antler estrogen really young
inflames the condition it can even lead
to blocked or compromised fallopian
tubes maybe even compromised
implantation more than on the pill it
takes a lot of that activity way perhaps
their best chances for pregnancy fall
immediately the month after stopping
stopping when their cycles come back
some women with polycystic ovary that
means they have so many eggs they don't
ovulate regularly they're on the pill
nice regular cycles sometimes they stop
the pill just for a couple months to
actually get some regular cycles there
are definitely people out there who
really the moment they stop the pill do
achieve pregnancy so if that's has to be
careful that's all queries of course
yeah and and what would be your advice
for women who are on some kind of
contraceptive and may want to get
pregnant too soon maybe after this whole
Cova thing when should they plan to get
off of that contraceptive so the good
news is for many women they're gonna
stop the pill and be able to get
pregnant right away there's a subset of
women who won't have that experience
though which would be unnerving if that
was their goal to be able to achieve
pregnancy they can know that's happening
to them if they stopped the pill and
nothing happens
so what I mean by nothing happens for
some women they just don't ovulate for a
little while that's actually relatively
common how can you know if you're
ovulating a couple of different ways you
could use an app like for example lots
of good brands out there another thing
a person could do is follow those on
those sticks at home those Elise
detection kits so clear blue clear
planning yeah yeah and and but even the
dollar store varieties just pee on a
stick every couple of days cheaper
sticks me better because it the money
starts to buggy after a while but the
point is you can you'll get a little
scourge that tells you that you're
ovulating and just after a person stops
the pill for some women it does take a
little while for that moment to kick yet
so it's not inherently problematic for
one or even two months of no regular
ovulation after spa permeability if it's
been more than one or two months though
there's there's a there's a there's an
issue it's called post pill amenorrhea
the pharma companies don't really
endorse the concept there they don't
think it's really real most physicians
do it's hard to say in an individual's
case if it's just exposing this
individuals underlying tendency to not
ovulate or for the secondary tip right
yeah that there is so many confounders
there so yeah so many confounders but I
might be reasonable if someone is
looking to achieve pregnancy to to to
predate stop from the pill by by a month
or two maybe a little earlier than they
had thought they wanted to actually
conceive that makes sense and is there
anything that women can do to get their
cycle back quicker once they come off
birth controls or is there anything that
we can kind of incorporate into our
lifestyle so there's a lot of things
that can be related to not having a
cycle when you're off the pill that
actually didn't have anything to do it
might just be exposing an underlying
underlying tendency so it's very
reasonable to look at lifestyle we are
in a time of great stress right now
stress is absolutely associated with
amenorrhea if you're not ovulating
regularly it might be because of some
some serious impacts that are happening
in your life at that moment it's very
situational you might decide that you
need to look for some online counseling
or other help but but it might also be a
reasonable reaction to a temporary
situation that's fine
other people are struggling with sleep
for the same reasons sometimes people's
cycles they start to get becoming
regular because of other hormone
imbalances like like hype like being
hypothyroid for example it's relatively
easy to test that you might be able to
do a virtual consult with your family
doctor though to go to a community lab
with a mask on and get it get it but
just just make sure you're firing some
mods another thing it can be is is just
around a person's own individual
lifestyle look at us all it's luck at
home right now some of this might be
exercising too much I suspect a lot of
us are not exercising enough and some of
us because of stress
let me stress not eating that's what
everybody a lot of people are stressed
eating and so weight can make a real
difference to this both being
underweight very clear if your BMI is
less than 17 and a half but also being
overweight no it's not true for
everybody as BMI increases that doesn't
inevitably mean that your cycle will get
irregular if you are overweight right
now that doesn't mean that just because
you lose weight your cycle is going to
become regular but if you go to a doctor
one of the first things they're gonna
say is if you can control your lifestyle
to control your weight into a into a
reassuring range and you'll be more
likely to ovulate regularly for many
women they might be able to
individualize that they might be able to
look back at a time in life when they
were ovulating regularly and try to make
sure that that's the weight that they're
right now that's the amount of exercise
that are doing right now maybe that's
the way to personalize your your
lifestyle to know that you've done the
right things or for you your body
because everyone's absolutely okay I
think that is fantastic advice for so
many women who are watching so thank you
so much dr. hanim I of course will be
leaving links below to the hana website
if anyone's interested in getting some
more information on fertility treatments
from one of the top fertility clinics as
far as I'm concerned so thank you very
kind of you to say and and for anybody
who's been watching this far but what
they might realize what they want more
than anything is is as his lifestyle
even dietary advice I'm not going to
claim to be the best person for that but
we work with some really great natural
paths there
that's the type of thing that can really
help especially during this time while
we're all stuck at home you can get some
individual is individualized advice so
you're not just doing a deep dive down
internet that's that's a tough place for
anybody I agree
okay thank you again so much have a
great day you too thank you again dr.
hanim I will definitely be leaving some
links below to Hannah's website if
you're interested in some more
information on fertility treatments from
one of the top fertility clinics now I
also want to loop in a fellow
evidence-based health youtuber mama dr.
Jones
so dr. Jones thank you so much for
joining me thank you I'm happy to be
here in chat with you guys
so as an OBGYN how long would you
encourage women to wait after they do
come off of some kind of birth control
before they start worrying about needing
to see a fertility specialist if they're
not getting their period back we do know
that the average time to resume having
periods after coming off the birth
control pill is write out a month but
that means that some people resume
period sooner than that and some people
take a lot longer so 90 days is probably
the top limit of where I would say I
need you to call me and let me know if
we haven't started a period by this
point so that we can look into it as far
as when should you see a fertility
specialist you know I think it kind of
depends on your OBGYN I personally do a
good amount of infertility evaluation
and treatment and a lot of generalist
OBGYNs do that so I would prefer for my
patients to come in and see me so that
we can kind of start that initial workup
and then if it's something that we can't
take care of in my clinic then we'll
send you on to an infertility specialist
okay that makes amazing sense and I
think that that that's a really helpful
information for a lot of women who are
just unsure people know before they went
on birth control pills that their
periods were very irregular and they
went on birth control pills to have a
little bit more predictability in their
cycles I would tell that patient you
should expect your periods to go back to
being irregular when you get off of her
birth control pill I still want you to
be in communication with me if that
happens but it won't be surprising yeah
that's a really good point because I
think the the birth control pill can
mask a lot of these kinds of
irregularities when it comes to one
cycle so it's good to be aware that
it's not necessarily because of the pill
it's because maybe something was already
present before you went on the pill so
that's a really good point as well
now do you ever hear concerns from any
of your patients in your clinic about
using the birth control pill and having
fertility issues down the road yeah I
think that that's a really common
question and concern that people have
and for me the easiest way to explain it
is that a single percentage of the
population is going to have infertility
issues when they go to attempt pregnancy
and when we look at people who have been
on a birth control pill you have what we
call recall bias you want to have
something to blame it on and when you
come off the pill in you have
infertility that ends upper corner
treatment it's really convenient if we
can say oh the birth control code cause
that unfortunately what we see is that
it's not usually that easy and we don't
always know what causes it but if you
look at groups of people who've been on
birth control pills and who've never
been on birth control pills the risk of
infertility between those two groups
is very similar if not exactly the same
and so this amongst hundreds of other
studies is the reason that we say it
does not affect your long-term fertility
it is true to say that you may have a
delay and return to ovulation and like
we just talked about for most people
that's about a month for some people it
can be up to three months but it
shouldn't cause actual infertility it
may just be that you need to come off
but I usually counsel our patients come
off your birth control pill win if you
got pregnant the month you came off it
would be okay but not when you have to
get pregnant the month you come off give
yourself some time and some flexibility
because we can't always plan these
things no no even if there is no issues
with the birth control pill that can
take women many months and many cycles
to conceive so it's always good to plan
for a little buffer in there so yeah
that's really good advice now of course
I want to make it clear that I am all
for reproductive choice and options but
in your experience are some birth
control methods less likely to cause
this delay in you know getting that
cycle back in the ovulation or is it
highly individuals so I'm talking about
like you know the pill versus IUDs
versus you know numerous all those kinds
of different options so it's going to be
very individual between the types
obviously if you're not on something
that is hormonal then you shouldn't have
that delay so if you're only using
natural family planning or you're only
using condoms then you shouldn't
experience that but anything you're
using that affects your hormones or that
includes hormones and even sometimes the
copper IUD as well you're going to see
that in some people it has no effect and
then some people it has delayed
ovulation affects as far as pill versus
patch versus nuvaring these three are
all the same medication just in a
different delivery form so those 3
should be really similar amongst people
you know how you as an individual react
to it should be the same between those
three for the depo-provera shot this can
be much more unpredictable and
resumption of ovulation when you've been
on the shot can be extremely long time
so if someone comes in and says you know
I don't wanna get pregnant this year but
I think we're gonna start trying you
know March of next year I usually would
recommend to them let's not do the depo
shot because it may be that you have
really delayed intervals to achieving
pregnancy with asha for the IUD I would
usually tell people to have it taken out
kind of the same as the pill you know
give yourself six months to go back to
normal periods but know that there's a
really good chance you'll be in the
majority of people who are able to get
pregnant far earlier than six months out
yeah that's really good advice so you
know surprises can happen so just be
ready for that I suppose absolutely
and is there a specific product that you
and your practice kind of gravitate
towards most when it comes to all of
those different options as far as what
type of birth control I recommend yeah I
people always ask me I think the most
common question when someone comes in to
talk about birth control with me is
what's the best one what do you
recommend right I have none it is we
have the I have a chart I think I've
gone through it on my channel at one
point that comes from bedsider.org
it goes over all of the pregnancy risks
and different tiers of birth control
from over-the-counter options to
pills patches brings shots to IUDs and
Nexplanon I think there's a better
reception I think it's very individual
so let go saying if you think a year
down the road you may want to try to get
pregnant then double prepare I may not
be the best option but if you think it's
gonna be three or five years and you
want to use the double shot I think
that's a really great option for some
people amazing well thank you so much
for all of your incredible insight and
your amazing content if you're not
already following Mama dr. Jones
everyone you've gotta hit up this
channel I think if you are a fan of my
kind of evidence-based content you're
going to love this amazing content
especially as it pertains to women's
health so I'm gonna leave some links
below to her channel so thank you again
for joining us thank you so much thank
you
thank you mama dr. Jones of course if
you're not already following this woman
you definitely need to I think if you
love my evidence-based approach you are
going to love hers as well especially as
it pertains to women's health so of
course I'm going to leave some links
below to her Channel and definitely
you're gonna want to subscribe now
bottom line folks it's difficult to
pinpoint an exact cause of infertility
post pill again there still needs to be
further more extensive research done to
explain why some women struggle to get
pregnant after coming off the pill while
others can just have sex the first month
and get pregnant until then my
recommendation is to speak to your
doctor about getting a referral to a
fertility clinic as soon as you feel
that you might be struggling the sooner
that you can get some answers the sooner
that you can get an action plan in place
to help you conceive in good time well
folks that is all for me today if you
like this video please be sure to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below with your experience with the pill
or really any questions that you may
want me to cover and investigate as part
of this fertility Files series subscribe
to the channel and I will see you next
time on Abby's kitchen bye